and it's precisely because we have the
hope
of that vaccine and the risk of new
strains
coming from overseas that we must take
additional steps now
to stop those strains from entering the
country so
yesterday we announced that we're
banning flights from
south america and portugal and to
protect us
against the risk of as yet unidentified
new strains we will also temporally
close
all travel corridors from 0-400
hours on monday following conversations
with the duval administrations we will
act together so this applies
across the whole of the uk this means
that if you come to this country
you must have proof of a negative
covid test that you have taken in the 72
hours before leaving
and you must have filled in your
passenger locator form
and your airline will ask for proof of
both before you take off
you may also be checked when you land
and face substantial fines
for refusing to comply and upon arrival
you must then quarantine
for 10 days not leaving your home for
any reason
at all or take another test on day five
and wait for proof of another negative
result and
we will be stepping up our enforcement
both
at the border and in country and it's
vital
to take these extra measures now when as
i say day by day hour by hour we are
making such
strides in protecting the population
we've now vaccinated
over 3.2 million people across the uk
doubling the numbers of last week that's
2.8 million people in england 225 000 in
scotland 126 000
in wales and 115 000 in northern ireland
yesterday alone we vaccinated around a
quarter of a million people
in england and that is still far more
than any other country
in europe